sur la place de l'indépendance
ils étaient plusieurs centaines venus
fêter l'annoncé du départ des troupes
françaises installé au mali depuis neuf
ans nous sommes pas la joie
[Musique]
mais savoir qu'il ne soit trop tard un
départ demandé ici par les manifestants
qui dénoncent l'enlisement de
l'opération barkan et la politique
étrangère de la france au mali la
semaine dernière les autorités de
transition ont demandé le retrait sans
délai des forces par canette à kouba à
retrait dans se félicite certains ici
qui s'est lui les nouveaux partenaires
de l'armée malienne
qui sont venus
à la déjà
en partenariat avec la russie qui
inquiète certains au sein de la classe
politique de l'opposition
et sur le plan militaire l'armée
malienne doit être avec qui aujourd'hui
le présent jusqu'à 10 l'état russe n'est
pas concerné donc on a affaire avec une
société privée qui viennent pour leur
intérêt pas autre chose ils vont pas
mourir pour le mali et le jour où on les
paiera pas c'est là qu'on sert à
abandonner un playboy malgré la montée
en puissance de l'armée malienne
revendiquée par les autorités de
transition huit soldats ont été tués il
ya quelques jours alors qu'il se
trouvait en opération au nord dans la
zone dite des trois frontières une zone
où des dizaines de civils ont récemment
été exécutés par l'état islamique au
grand sahara pour cet élu de la région
de gao les populations locales font
régulièrement l'objet de représailles de
la part de groupes djihadistes qui
opèrent dans la zone des populations
livrées à elles mêmes qui demandent le
retour de la sécurité il faut que nous
mêmes nous reçoit un rap dire dans
l'ensemble les cours parmi les groupes
signataires ne sont pas un républicain
ce sera très difficile parce que pour
nous la sécurité il faut connaître les
terres il faut savoir qui est qui dans
ce territoire immense qui échappe
aujourd'hui au contrôle de l'état les
populations demandent la mise en place
d'une armée nationale reconstituer prévu
dans l'est dispositions de l'accord de
paix d'alger